if there's one skincare ingredient that
works it's retinol pretty much everyone
agrees whatever skin concern you have
it's one of your Best Bets but is it all
a scam quite a few dermatologists and
scientists don't think ranol works there
is very little if any trustworthy
evidence available to support the use of
retinol containing products to improve
the appearance of aged skin I think they
are a total waste of time and money and
I can see where they're coming from when
I started looking at skincare during my
Medicinal Chemistry PhD I saw a huge
difference between what scientists are
report is good evidence and what I was
seeing for skincare but after 12 years
of studying skincare science learning
about the Cosmetic industry and getting
qualified as a cosmetic chemist I feel
like I can finally explain to you why
skincare science looks so un sciency and
how to find products that work now some
of you are probably thinking she's just
defending the scam because she's been
sponsored by skincare companies but a
lot of non-sponsored scientists and
dermatologists agree and once I break it
down I think a lot of things that you've
noticed about skincare will suddenly
make a lot more more sense and you'll
find it easier to pick out
evidence-based skincare products retinol
is a retinoid these are ingredients
based on vitamin A and they're the
superstars of skincare they work for
lots of things like acne pigment and
wrinkles but not all of them have the
same level of evidence some of these are
drugs they have been extensively studied
and that's where a lot of that great
reputation for retinoids comes from but
what about retinol PubMed is a database
where most peer-review clinical trials
are listed this is where products have
actually been tested on someone's skin
and then other scientists have looked
over the study before it got published
if we do a really basic search for
retinol clinical trials it's not really
looking great we've got 39 results and a
lot of these aren't actually on retinol
on skin this is a pretty typical Ral
study that you'll see and it's actually
one of the better ones we've got 40
subjects which is pretty low by medical
standards but actually really good by
skincare standards it's Placebo control
which means the skincare product was
compared with a cream that didn't have
any active
it's double blind which means both the
volunteers and the people taking the
measurements of the skin didn't know
which product was which so they are
hopefully less biased but you can see
here we've got retinol it's also
combined with lactose and glycolic acid
so you don't actually know if it's the
retinol working or if it's one of the
other ingredients most of the authors
are also from Johnson and Johnson which
is the company that makes the products
so there is a potential conflict of
interest there and we haven't even
opened the paper yet so I'm sure once we
get in there there'll be even more ISS
so why does the evidence for the best
skincare ingredient look like this well
a lot of this is the government's fault
thanks most countries draw a line
between drugs and cosmetics drugs are
defined as products that can treat
disease or they can change the structure
or function of skin before an ingredient
can become a drug it has to go through
an approval process this involves doing
a whole bunch of studies including on
lots and lots of people to show that it
is actually effective the company then
takes all this data and submits a to a
regulatory agency they make sure there's
enough evidence to say that it works and
it becomes a drug on the other hand
Cosmetics are defined as products that
have superficial effects they just
change the appearance of skin ranol is
classified as a cosmetic so this kind of
makes it seem like rational doesn't work
it feels a lot like this do you know
what they call alternative medicine
that's been proved to work medicine what
this is missing and this is crucial a
lot of the time whether something
becomes a drug is less about what it
does and doesn't do and more about other
reasons this drug versus cosmetic
definition was created almost a 100
years ago before we as a species
realized bloody everything can change
the structure and function of skin at
least in little ways including water and
even just a piece of plastic tape I mean
look at these effects it is pretty
intense for something that literally
just sits on top of your skin and
doesn't even go in and some ingredients
are drugs in one country and cosmetics
in other countries it's not like you can
tell a molecule what it can and can't
legally do to your skin after you've
crossed the border you just can't they
won't hear you they don't have ears so
this is a common misconception how
Cosmetics are legally defined doesn't
match what Cosmetics are actually doing
to your skin but at the same time it
would be ridiculous and unnecessary to
regulate water and sticky tape as drugs
the way it mostly Works in practice is
that Cosmetics aren't meant to claim
that they can change the structure or
function of skin and if cosmetic
companies start selling really potent
and potentially dangerous stuff then the
government steps in but with retinoids
you might be wondering they all kind of
do the same thing they work in the same
way but some of them made it to the drug
side why is retinol over here this is a
really good question and it's almost
entirely a historical accident here's a
dermatologist who was involved in the
original research on retinoids for skin
how did it come about that retinol is
over the counter and retinoids or
prescription the reason is retinol has
been in in a lot of products including
cosmetics for a long time for his
antioxidant properties so it was already
in over the coun of products and then as
as it became apparent and and the work
of Sean Kang and John wores where they
showed retinol was a pre-drug of
retinoic acid once we became aware of
all that then obviously retinol might
have some some benefit and it it clearly
does there are many many good really
good studies that show that's definitely
benefit so the FDA couldn't say well we
can't allow this over the counter
because it's already there you know for
another reason just in a different
conentration so there are some good
reasons why Ral isn't legally classified
as a drug but if it works then where are
the scientific studies here's the thing
with the peerreview scientific
literature not everything has an equal
chance of ending up in here there are a
lot of good reasons why we don't see
highquality peer-review clinical trials
on Cosmetics that often yes one of these
reasons is that a lot of stuff probably
doesn't work that well but a really
important reason that gets missed a lot
is there is just not that much incentive
to do them research costs a lot
especially clinical trials most P
research is funded by taxes it's a lot
easier to get funding to research heart
disease than skin and within skin
research it's a lot easier to get money
to study drugs approved to treat medical
conditions than how retinol makes skin
look nice that means more skin studies
are funded by ingredient and skincare
companies which isn't as nice because
there are potential conflicts of
interest
but even if the studies were 10,000%
honest that still changes the sorts of
studies that get funded as someone who
owns skin I would love more highquality
clinical trials on skincare it's nice
simple direct evidence you literally put
the thing on a bunch of faces and see
what happens but that's not how
companies think they don't have skin
back to the government companies are
going to do less trials on Cosmetics
clinical trials are actually needed
before you sell a drug but Cosmetics
don't need them if a company doesn't
need to pay for an expensive thing they
are probably not going to pay for that
expensive thing and it is expensive back
when I had less back pain a proper
clinical trial for a Dermatology drug
cost $1.5 million not adjusted for
inflation that drug versus cosmetic
definition means that even if a cosmetic
did something in a clinical trial the
company can't just slap that on a
billboard so it isn't exactly the most
guaranteed return on investment compared
to everything else a company could spend
their money on let's say a company has
decided to pay for a clinical trial and
they often do despite all of these
barriers well-designed experiments are a
great way to test what works and make
better products yay scientific method
but publishing a study in a peer review
journal is a choice the company could
also just not publish it and just use
the findings to improve their own
products instead of giving free info to
their competitors and this happens a lot
I've consulted for some companies who
invest a lot in R&D and it is extremely
obvious that what we actually see see is
a tiny sliver of the actual research
they've done now for academic scientists
doing good research and not publishing
it in a piew journal is super weird I
know because Academia is where I was
made and it's because the incentives are
so different there part of why academics
publish papers is because it contributes
to scientific knowledge it's just how
science is done and that idea
contributes to a lot of Industry
publishing too but a very big part of it
for academics is that's how you keep
your job it's publish or perish your
peer-review Publications are really
important when universities decide who
to hire and who to promote and when
research funding gets decided so the
peerreview studies that do come out are
going to lean towards maximum benefit to
the company at a minimal cost and a lot
of the time this is just the opposite of
good study design for example a
well-designed trial to test Ral would
mean it's tested on its own against a
vehicle control that means you're
testing a cream with retinol against the
exact same cream without retinol to make
sure it is that retinol working if
you're big Cosmetic Company you've just
paid a whole bunch of money to show that
rational and ingredient that every other
company can use in their products works
on the other hand you can spend the same
amount of money and test your specific
rational formula against a plain cream
or even against nothing just to rig it a
bit and make your product look better so
if you're looking at it as purely an
investment it kind of leans very much
one way welld design also usually means
more participants repetition is really
important in science the more times you
test something the more confident you
can be that your result isn't just a
one-off fluke in drug trials they'll
test on hundreds or thousands of people
most cosmetic trials have less than 30
people why would you pay for 300 people
when you could just pay for 30 and still
be doing more than everyone else so
there are a lot of reasons why a
cosmedic company probably isn't going to
pay big bucks for a well-designed
clinical trial on Ral that they'll
publish in a p review journal that ends
up on PubMed the only real incentive
would be to get new customers who are
nerdy enough to be impressed by a welld
design clinical trial but they don't
already think rol works this is a really
really tiny group of people again just
an awful investment especially since
pretty much everyone who understands
retinoid pharmacology accepts that at
least some retinol products work so why
why do so many scientists think rational
works even though we don't have that
many highquality clinical trials even
cigman who invented tranon and has a
reputation for maybe hyping it up a
little bit too much even he says retinol
which is a competing ingredient works I
love clinical trials I think all
scientists do thingo and face face
change nice nice but I think sometimes
we forget that the whole point of
science is to build an understanding of
the world so we don't have to directly
test everything clinical trials have
have been important for such a long time
because human biology is really
complicated clinical trials aren't
really used for better understood areas
of science like astrophysics it can be
hard to accurately predict what happens
when you take a pill the ingredients
have to travel through your digestive
system get absorbed go into your blood
get processed by your liver and then end
up in the right part of your body before
it works but skin products are less
complex they just have to go through a
relatively short distance through your
skin so it is a lot easier to work out
what's going on from other types of
evidence and our scientific
understanding of human biology is also
improving for example in toxicology
there's been a lot more use of new
approach methods instead of just
directly testing on animals or people
and this sort of scientific reasoning
and extrapolation is used in clinical
trials too if a drug Works in a clinical
trial in one place we assume that it's
going to work in lots of other people in
lots of other places maybe years after
the original and that's because thanks
to science we know that human biology
doesn't evolve that quickly drug
molecules aren't really affected by
where you are clinical trials for tranon
didn't tell people whether they should
be sitting or standing while applying it
because again thanks to science we know
that's not going to change how it works
so there's actually a lot of other
scientific evidence on retinol and when
you put it all together it builds a
really convincing case that if we had
the incentive to do highquality clinical
trials they would find that retinol
works one of the key pieces of evidence
is that in your skin retinol can be
converted to tretin which is an approved
drug there's a lot of evidence that
tonone works and we also know a lot
about how it works its pharmacological
mechanism of action so far this isn't a
slim dunk we still need that tranon that
gets formed from the retinol to end up
in the right place and at a high enough
concentration luckily we do have
evidence for this we also have evidence
that applying normal amounts of rol to
skin will change the level of substances
inside the skin these are the same ones
that change with tranon and they're
expected to be an important part of how
trano actually works and for each of
these we have multiple types of evidence
we have studies on mice on people on
bits of skin removed from people on
different types of isolated human skin
cells you might have also experienced
some evidence for yourself if you've
ever used a little bit too much ragol
you might have noticed a special kind of
peeling it's not the same as the kind of
peeling you get from other irritating
products there is a delay and it feels
like you just have a little bit too much
skin this is a pretty unique side effect
of retinoids it has a special name
retinization or retinoid dermatitis and
it happens because of how retinoids work
activating retinoid acid receptors
triggers the epidermal growth factor
pathway and this leads to more cells
being produced in the top layers of your
skin there's also those not as high
quality clinical trials that we do have
despite all of this lack of incentive
making the bar way higher for conducting
and Publishing them retinol still has a
lot that show promising results and this
evidence includes studies from
independent research groups that don't
have funding from cosmetic companies a
lot of the studies that were funded by
cosmetic companies were done in
conjunction with independent academic
researchers and the industry funding for
these studies comes from lots of
different cosmetic companies there are
also studies on other cosmetic retinoids
with results that wouldn't really make
sense unless retinol worked it's just
really really unlikely that all of these
scientists and companies are part of
some huge conspiracy that's been going
on for almost 30 years so in this
situation where there are very good
practical reasons why high quality
peer-review clinical trials aren't there
and there is an overwhelming amount of
other scientific evidence that something
works I think it's really reasonable to
conclude that rational probably works
now I'm not saying that you can't choose
to only use ingredients that have
well-designed clinical trials that is a
completely reasonable personal choice
but saying that the only ingredients
that work are the ones with high quality
clinical trials and anything without
that specific type and level of evidence
is completely useless that is actually
unscientific and there are some upsides
that cosmetic retinoids have that drug
retinoids don't and I'll be talking
about those in a different video I've
mostly talked about retinol which is the
skincare ingredient with the most
evidence behind it but there are a lot
of other things that we can take from
this journey that can help us find other
effective ingredients this is the lab
muffin Matrix it shows how to think
about the evidence when you're deciding
if a skincare product has a good chance
of working the left hand side is about
ingredients you want to see if the
active ingredient can theoretically work
this is looking at things like chemical
properties mechanism of action cell
studies and animal studies do we know
how it works what it's interacting with
inside the skin can it get into skin you
also want to see if the active
ingredient has been actually tested on
people's skin we're looking for clinical
studies and biopsy evidence now the
right hand side is about specific
product formulas again you want to see
if it can theoretically work and if that
formula has actually being tested on
actual people some ingredients are
easier to formulate with so you don't
have to do quite as much guess work but
others are more annoying like if they're
unstable which is the case for a lot of
retinoids I'll be talking more about
this but a good General guideline is to
look for products from companies who
invest in product development and for
all of these if there are more different
types of evidence more different
scientists contributing to this body of
evidence more repetition of findings you
can be more confident about the
conclusion once you have a retinoid
product you'll need to know how to apply
it so I take you through that in this
video the next best skincare active is
probably vitamin C and I have a guide to
choosing those
two